So you know how to solve for a variable using numbers. First we multiplied those
sides by the quantity 5 plus y, we distributed the positive 3 here, and then we
subtracted 15 and divided by 3. But what if we had an equation like this one and
we wanted to solve for y? Notice the setup of these two equations are nearly
identical. It turns out that we can solve for y by following nearly the same
exact steps here. Instead of using numbers, though, we'll have variables. First
we'll multiply each side of our equations by x plus y. Then we'll distribute z
to both of these terms, to get zx plus zy equals one x. When we're at this step,
we want to isolate y. Remember we wanted to solve for y or this variable and get
it by itself. So we should isolate this on one side of the equation by
subtracting zx from both sides. We'll get zy is equal to x minus z times x.
These are not like terms so we can't combine them. The variables are different.
And finally to isolate y we divide both sides by z. This gives us with one y
equal to x minus z times x all divided by z. This is pretty amazing, we actually
solved an equation for a variable in terms of other variables. So, in this work
we really multiplied by x plus y first Then we distributed the positive z to
each of these terms. Next we subtracted zx from both sides of our equation to
get the y alone on one side. And to solve for y, or to get one y, we divided by
z, which gave us our final answer. See if you can look back at this work and
this work, to draw comparisons between the two. They're not that much different.
We're really just trying to get 1 variable solved in terms of others. When
you're doing the comparison, think about z as being 3. And think about x as
being 5. This is a skill that might come in handy with other courses. Especially
when you're trying to solve for certain variables. Maybe you don't want to find
this variable, z. Maybe you want to find x or y. These 2 equations are actually
the same. They just look different. This equation and this equation are actually
equivalent. They just look different in from. This one is solve for z, and this
one is solve for y. If I knew the values of x and y, I could quickly compute the
value of z. But, maybe, instead, I really want to find the value of y. If I know
the values of x and z, I can quickly find the value of y by plugging into this
equation.